لسيد بعض من موسكو هل لهذا السبب
اقدمت روسيا على ضرب العاصمه كييف اليوم
بهذا الشكل وبهذا التطور ام ان هناك اسباب
اخرى ورسائل اخرى ربما من وراء هذا التطور
العسكريون الروس يبدو انهم يريدون ان
يغرقوا او يسيطروا على الدفاعات الجويه
التي
بنيت
بدعم كبير من الغرب
وانظمته لذلك كان هناك
هجمتان من مكثفتان باعداد كبيره
نحن
الدفاعات الجويه ما تزال تعمل بالرغم انه
وصلت ضربات مباشره وايضا هناك صواريخ تم
ايقافها من المهم الان بالنسبه لروسيا ان
تظهر انه يمكنها التغلب على الدفاعات
الجويه
الاوكرانيه
وبعد
نصف منتصف مايو كان هناك
هجمات
بالمسيرات والصواريخ
ووصلت الى اهدافها وهو يبدو انه فعال اذا
هجمات فعاله وهذا نوع
من الحرب النفسيه وايضا له مفعول عسكري
يظهر قدره روسيا على التغلب على الدفاعات
الجويه
التي تم توفيرها من الغرب وهذا طبعا سيؤثر
على معنويات
الاوكرانيين شعبا وعسكريين
اذا في حال نجحت اعتقد اذا انه سيكون هناك
المزيد من هذه الهجمات
هل هو فقط سيد بلقنهاور لانه هذا هذا
الكلام يقوله الاوكرانيون ايضا ان الروس
ان الجيش الروسي الان الهجمات الروسيه
هدفها استنزاف الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
وانهاك هذه المنظومه وما فيها من عناصر
غربيه
معدات غربيه لكن الهجوم اليوم في واضح
النهار كان في وسط كيف في منطقه حساسه
فيها القصر الرئاسي فيها مناطق حساسه فيها
منشات حساسه مراكز اتخاذ قرار هل فقط هو
ايرباك الدفاعات الجويه ام ان هنالك قرارا
روسيا الان
بالوصول الى يعني القياده الاوكرانيه
بتصفيه القياده الاوكرانيه وسمعنا ذلك
مرارا من على سبيل المثال
بالنسبه للزعامه الاوكرانيه يمكن
استهدافها
بنجاح كبير ولا اعتقد ان ذلك حدث
اقد ان السببين يمكن ان يكون وجهين
وحدثت هجومات ووصلت وردت روسيا ايضا على
بعض الهجمات الاوكرانيه
اذا
الهدف هو التغلب على الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه
التي
تستخدم فيها الصواريخ الدفاعيه
الغربيه
ومن المهم هو بمثابه لعبه الشطرنج
ما تسمى في الاربعينيات ازمات الالمانيه
اذا هو لها مفعول
نفسي اذا الهدف هو اظهار
للاوكرانيين ان الدفاعات الغربيه لن لن
تحميهم من القوه الروسيه